in the question corner of volume 105 the
author of One Piece dropped a bombshell
about Zara's lineage because we finally
get confirmation that Zoro is in fact
related to The Sword God that Yuma that
he fought back on Thriller bar we also
finally learned the identity of zoro's
long-lost parents and even some shocking
clues that not just one but two of the
current Admirals might be part of zoro's
extended family starting with zaro's
relation to the Yuma because when you
look at the family tree you can see that
Zoro got his name roronoa from his
grandfather and it was actually his
grandmother who is a direct descendant
of Yuma and the shimotsuki clan of one
in case you didn't know we first learned
about ryuma on the Zombie Island for La
bar during the final battle Zoro duels
and defeats the animated corpse of the
long dead legendary Samurai and little
did we know that he was actually
fighting his ancient ancestor which may
explain why Ruma decided to give Zoro
his famous sword shui after being
defeated and while eventually Zoro
returned this blade during the wano arc
now that we know that shoes we belong to
zoro's ancestor we would like to see him
reclaim the famous blade before the end
of the story but this is only the
beginning of this ridiculous family tree
we already knew that 55 years before the
current storyline a single ship escaped
the samurai country of wano with 25
people on board that's because the
borders of wano were always close now
eventually this ship landed at a small
village in the East blue where the
samurai of mono saved the Village from
Bandits this Village then later became
known as shimodski Village the same
place where Zoro then learned how to
fight with a sword and it is here where
the family tree starts branching out on
the ship washimotsuki kuzaburu who we
first learned about from kuzuki Odin's
father back in chapter 955. he was a
famous swordsmith who crafted two of
Zorro's previous swords the waro
ichimonji and enma we also recently
learned that he was also somewhat of a
Minter to Zorro as we see in the
flashback from chapter 1033 when he
gives sorrow two of his first actual
swords that he then used to challenge
kawina zaro's first rival and the person
that he made a promise with to become
the greatest swordsman in the world and
this shimosuke kozaburu then married a
girl from the village and became the
father of koshiro who was the master of
the dojo where Zoro trains koshiro then
again later married someone else and
became the father of kuina but with this
new information from the question Corner
as you can see right here we learned
that Zoro and kuina were actually both a
part of the shimonsky family tree though
whether they're directly related as
cousins or something or more distantly
related is still unknown which takes us
back to Zara's direct lineage which is
the most interesting part as it gives us
some incredibly juicy clues about zoro's
future and you won't believe what other
powerhouses in the one piece world might
actually be a part of zoro's family but
before we can get into those juicy bits
here I want to mention that while it is
incredibly exciting to learn more about
zoro's past it is equally disappointing
for me that we're not learning about all
of this in the main story I mean really
how many opportunities were there during
wanos where you could have shown own
this same information but for whatever
reason Ichiro order decided not to it's
possible that he thought it just wasn't
important enough or maybe it was so
important that he wanted to spend time
on it that he just didn't have so it was
eventually just cut in the prolonged
chaos of wano whatever the actual reason
is remember that Sanji got not one but
two backstories once during the baratia
arc and another one during the whole
cake Island art an entire Arc only
dedicated to his entire family so I for
one think that in the four years that we
spent in wano could have at least gotten
like one chapter or so on zoro's past
even if it's just as a side story in my
personal opinion it would have made
zoro's role in wano even more impactful
I mean just think of scenes like the
execution of his relative shimotsuke
asoye with that being said though let's
continue with the family tree because
there are actually some insane secrets
that we can learn from zoro's family
names starting with Zara's grandmother
she maltske Fuji furico was on the same
ship that departed wano 55 years ago and
we're told in the question Corner that
she is the older sister of this guy who
we first met back in chapter 1024 during
Yamato's flashback and this guy is no
one less than the former daimyo of the
Ringo region in wano shimotsuke ushimaru
who for a while were thought was
actually zoro's father well it turns out
he was just his great uncle and we've
speculated a lot before on this channel
about zoro's future after the straw had
to find the one piece but since it is
now confirmed that Zorro was related to
oshimaru do you think that future Zorro
could return to wano to reclaim his
family's former role as a daimyo But
continuing down the family tree zoro's
grandmother fulico married a swordsman
from shimotsky Village in the East blue
named roronoa pinzoro clearly Zorro was
named after his father so we might as
well call him Junior and we can assume
that pinzoro and furico are both dead
well keep watching to find out what
insane main Clues we can learn from
their names next we have Zorro's father
arashi all we know about this man is
that he has spiky hair and that he died
in a battle against Pirates which makes
me wonder if he died protecting the
village or if he was a pirate himself
however Zorro clearly remembers enough
about his father to have named an attack
after him Hana arashi which we saw when
he wielded soga King and his sword
together during the fight on ends Lobby
now arashim was married to zaro's Mother
tenna but similarly all we know is that
she was the daughter of thieving Bandits
and that she died of some illness which
does seem to be a common fate for straw
hat characters mothers since both usop
and sanji's mother also died from
illnesses good nami's mother also have
suffered the same fate is what I'm
asking here and with both of his parents
dead that leaves our green-haired
swordsman orphaned at the dojo in
shimotsky village and while this is all
we've gotten so far for the family tree
in the questions corner there is a lot
more that we can actually speculate
played based on the names of Zoro direct
family thanks to the one piece Creator
Sandman on my all-time favorite platform
Twitter it is clear that zoro's family
names are based off of traditional
Japanese dice gambling pinzuro zoro's
grandfather means to get double ones
foodie called his grandmother meets a
person who rolls the dice arashi zaro's
father means to get three of the same
number and Terra is a possible
connection to terazeni or vigorish which
is a fee taken by gambling companies and
we can even see that Zorro himself is
quite fond of dice during wano in
chapter 929 yasu who is actually Zara's
relative shimons claims that Zoro had
just won a large sum of money from a
dice gambling house also we do know that
Zoro does have a tendency to often leave
things to chance as he did back in the
sword shot back in low town in chapter
97 but what is really most interesting
about this family of dice gamblers is
the other character who might also share
this connection with the shimotsuki
family remember that back on Josh Rosa
we are introduced to this blind Gambler
who turns out to be the Admiral fujitora
and what is he gambling with dice
solid connection and even Beyond this
fujitora has so many Japanese elements
that could be from wano like his
clothing or his samurai swords we also
know that fujitora was born 54 years ago
which was after the shimotsky ship left
wano so it would make sense that he's
out and about in the world instead of
still being stuck inside juano's borders
we also know that at some point he
blinded himself because he had seen too
many atrocities so it could be that one
day he returned to wano so all the
devastation left by kaido and then took
the blood to his eyes and actually
another Marine with Ty's tuano and
possibly the shimotsuka is sento Maru
the personal bodyguard of Dr vegapun
sentimara's appearance is heavily based
on a Japanese folklore Samurai called
sakata No kintoki and Santo maro's name
is written in kanji just like the people
of wano so it's possible that he could
be a descendant of the shimotsuke or
another person who left Juan or 55 years
ago and if sentimaru is from wano it is
quite likely that another Marine is as
well this time the Admiral he's speaks
with a very similar respectful
samurai-like and old-fashioned tone and
Santa motto even refers to him with the
honorific title of Uncle hence the
reveal of zoro's true family tree of
course also added some feel to the fire
surrounding Marine Captain toshigi we've
long known that she looks strikingly
similar to Karina and with all that
we've learned in this question corner it
is even more likely that she is actually
a shimotsuke krina also could have been
another descendant of kozaburo or
another unnamed shimotsky from that ship
and if that's the case does tashigi even
know that she's a descendant of the
Samurai of mono in fact even Zorro and
his childhood friend Karina seem to be
unaware of their famous ancestors which
kind of makes you wonder why no one ever
told them were their parents trying to
protect them from the Marines or even
keep Zoro and Karina from returning to
wano but we don't have the answer to
that question quite yet if you want to
learn more about Zoro as a kid and the
true origin of his dream to be the
strongest swordsman in the world you can
watch this video about m every single
backstory in one piece right here Shanks
for watching